20 years ago, our world changed forever.
A sunny morning became one of our darkest days.
When there was nothing we could say,...
...we did all we could to search for answers...
...and meaning to somehow find our way.
It was in these moments that we realized the power of our own strength.
And together, the strength of our collective power.
Two decades later, we see a city that defines perseverance,...
...rebuilt through courage,...
...resolve and triumph.
Today and forever, we remember those who can't be here with us.
And honor those who protect us.
And as we look ahead, we will always hold these stories...
...and these memories in our hearts...
...and in our minds and vow to never ever forget.